[موسيقى]
ونحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد يجتمعوا قاده
العالم بقمه العشرين في اندونيسيا وعلى
طاوله البحث الازمات يغلب عليها طبع
الاقتصاديه ولا تذل المشاكل الاقتصاديه
منذلاع الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وبدء
ظهور انعكاساتها تتمثل بطباطئ النمو
الاقتصادي العالمي هو دخول مرحله الوقود
الاقتصاديه بكثير من البلدانه وقال تقرير
لورثه جونيور في هذا الاطار ان الحد من
ضغوط الاقتصاديه غير وارد حاليا في البنوك
المركزيه ستزيد اسعار الفائده في المستقبل
ايضا وذكرته سيجنال لان صندوق النقد
الدولي يتوقعوا ان يحقق الاقتصاد العالمي
نموا بنسبه اثنين فاصله 7% فقط خلال عام
2020 مع توقع ان يسجل 31 اقتصادا من بين
اثنين وسبعين اقتصادانا خطاطا للانتاج
لربعين متتاليين في وقت ما خلال هذا العام
هاعمل مقبل
[موسيقى]
مناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفينا من القاهره
دكتور فخري الفقي مساعد صندوق النقد
الدوليه سابق اهلا بك من راس الخيمه
المهندس خالد العوضي مستشار في شركه هوك
الطاقه اهلا بك ومن باريس
اهلا بكم ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا
من القاهره معك يا دكتور فخري دكتور فخري
في الواقع رغم ان هذه القمه التي تحتضنها
بالي تخيم عليها صحيح مواضيع وملفات
سياسيه ولكن يبقى اصل هذه القمه اقتصادي
بامتياز وهذه القمه في نسخها السابقه
وخاصه بعض ازمه 2008 كانت نجحت في اخراج
العالم من هذه الازمه وقدمت حلولا حقيقيا
هل هذه المره هذه القمه في هذه المرحله
الحرجه قادره ان تخرج بحلول حقيقيه
لمحاوله على الاقل همم همم احداث شيء
ايجابي فما يخص هذه الازمه الاقتصاديه
التي يعيش العالم
همم
ضيوفك الكرام فيما يتعلق همم يعني همم قمه
العشرين في بالي باندونيسيا تعتبر طبعا
هذه المره الاولى تعقد اندونيسيا واتمنى
التوفيق لقاده همم مجموعه العشرين في
الوصول الى همم يعني مخرج من هذه الازمه
الاقتصاديه الكبيره الغير مسبوقه في هذه
الحلقه كما حدث في 2008 والتي تم يعني رفع
مستوى التمثيل في قمه العشرين على مستوى
رؤساء الدول والحكومات في هذه الحاله على
اي الاحوال همم يعني العالم همم يعني هناك
ثلاثه اقتصادات كبرى في العالم تعاني من
حاله همم من همم الركود او التباطل في
النمو الاقتصادي
همم الاقتصاد الاول وهو الاقتصاد الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ويعاني من معدلات تضخم
غير مسبوقه تستخدمها بتشدد نقدي وهمم
ومالي في المستقبل الى تنخفض معدلات
التضخم باسرع ما يمكن دون الدخول في شبح
او ما يشبه الركود في سنه 23 ايضا فيما
يتعلق بالاقتصاد الصيني ثاني اقتصاد في
العالم يعاني من تباطؤ في النمو شكل
الملحوظ بسبب الرهون العقاريه وايضا بعض
البؤر ال- ال- الكرونا في الصين الى همم
بالطبع الصين تخفض من معادلات الفائده
وليس رفع الفائده لانها لا تعاني كثيرا من
معدلات تضخم بالشكل غير المسروق في همم
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ثم الاتحاد
الاوروبي الكتله الثالثه والاقتصاد الاكبر
الكبير في هذه الحاله الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي تعاني في هذه الحاله من ازمه
الطاقه ومعدلات ضخم همم غير مسبوقه وهمم
اختناقات في سلاسل الامداد خاصه بالنسبه
للطاقه في هذه الحاله وتدخل هي الاخرى في
حاله من همم التباطؤ الذي يمكن ان يؤدي
الى الركود في العام القادم لذلك قمه
العشرين امامها حلول همم للخروج من هذه
الازمه نمره واحد ان يبقى في نوع من
التنسيق بين في السياسه النقديه للبنوك
المركزيه ليه خاصه دول السبعه الكبرى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انجلترا فرنسا
المانيا اليابان وكندا وايطاليا الدول
مجموعه السبعه داخل مجموعه العشرين عليها
مسؤوليه كبيره بالاضافه الى صندوق النقد
الدولي في التنسيق والتناغم بين اس ايه
يعني سياسات النقديه والماليه يعني الان
ومستقبلا لان هناك عدم تناغم موجود
اليابان معدل للفائده فيها بالسالب ولم
تتغير معدلات الفائده في بنك المركزي الي
حتى الان لابد من التنسيق بين السياسات
النقديه للبنوك المركزيه الرئيسيه للدول
السبعه الكبيره اا فيما يتعلق
بمسؤوليه كبرى ايضا تتعلق به سلاسل
الامداد لابد من علاج سلاسل الامداد خاصه
لابد من ايقاف باي السبل وبكل يعني الطرق
وبال- بالطرق الدبلوماسيه وغير
الدبلوماسيه همم يعني القوه الناعمه في
هذه الحلقه ايقاف هذه الحرب الدائره همم
مؤثره ايضا اقتصاديه في هذه الحياه دكتور
وعلى
في همم المواد الاوليه التي كانت تنتجها
وكانت تصادرها روسيا واوكرانيا يتحدث عن
هذه الازمه وبالتالي يعيد الى نفس هذا
الاطار الاطار الازمه ولكن خليني استاذ
خالد اكون همم او احمل شيء من الايجابيه
مع حضرتك في سؤالي وان شاء الله تكون هناك
ايجابيه كذلك من خلال اجابتك نحن تحدثنا
على امتداد الوقت الماضي من هذه الحلقه
على الازمات عددنا الازمات السياسيه
الازمه العسكريه الروسيه همم امكانيه ان
تدلع حرب نوويه
واثارها وتداعياتها على الازمه الاقتصاديه
ولكن هل هناك مؤشرات ايجابيه يمكن للقاده
ان يبنوا عليها من خلال هذه القمه بغض
النظر على كل التفاصيل تفاصيل ازمات التي
نعيشها هل هناك مؤشرات هل هناك دلائل ولو
بسيطه يمكن ان تحملنا من السيئ همم الى
الاحسن بقليل
نعم من الناحيه الايجابيه في المشاكل
بالاسعار والتضخم في الطاقه والغذاء نعم
انا ارى ان هناك ايجابيه من اولها طبعا
اللقاء بين الرئيس الامريكي والرئيس
الصيني للعلم يعني من من سنتين منذ تولى
الرئيس الامريكي الرئاسه لم يقابل الرئيس
الصيني فهذه بادره ايجابيه همم يعني تجسد
اهداف القمه الاقتصاديه وهو بناء همم
الثقه بين الدول للتوصل الى حلول اقتصاديه
وترك الخلافات الاقتصاديه ويعني
والتهديدات الاقتصاديه بين امريكا والصين
اكبر اقتصاديين في العالم لانه همم هذا
الاجتماع له تاثير على كل العالم
بايجابيات في المجال الاقتصادي اما في
الامور السياسيه لا اعتقد ان هناك
ايجابيات طبعا
[موسيقى]
ناتي الى الحلول في
الجانب الغذاء والطاقه طبعا
اكبر اقتصاديات او اكبر 20 اقتصاديات
العالم تجتمع هذه الايام للنظر في كل
القضايا ومنها قضايا التضخم في الطاقه
والغذاء وهذا شيء ايجابي طبعا
بجلوسهم في هذه القمه بعد جلوسهم في قمه
المناخ اللي هي كوب 27 في مصر يعني كلهم
في نفس تقريبا في اسبوعين يعني هذا شيء
يثير الايجابيه هذه القمع وهذه الاجتماعات
على مستويات على مستوى رؤساء الدول يثير
الايجابيه للتواصل الى حلول ايجابيه في
هذه يعني راينا تثبيت همم مثلا الدعم
المادي والتحفيزات الماديه للدول الناميه
في كوب 27 وايضا سيكون همم
في هذه القمه همم هل يكون هناك طرح
للافكار بطريقه صريحه همم هل على الاقل ان
لم نتوصل الى حل او توافق على امكانيه
ايجاد حل تعتقد بان هذه القيمه عموما هي
مجال لترح الافكار لابراز همم نوايا بعض
الدول بطريقه صريحه لتوجيه الطرف المقابل
على الاقل
لمحاوله الكشف عن جزء من استراتيجيات هذه
دول وهذا قد يكون مفيد كذلك في فهم الاخر
نعم طبعا
تبادل الاراء وطرح النوايا في اجتماعات
مثل هذه يعني تسجل كعهود عهود على الدول
وايضا لا ننسى ان هناك ايضا اجتماعات اخرى
اييه خارج هذه القمم من
تدعم كل مساء ينتج عنه وما سيطرح فيه يا
ليست الاجتماع
التي تطرح ايضا هناك ايضا خلف الكواليس
اجتماعات اخرى بين هذه الدول لطرح ما ست
ما ستطرحه في قمه الملح في قمه همم الجيت
20 قمه العشرين حالها حال كل القمم
العالميه هي لا يعني لا تحدث كل شهر او كل
سنه على مدى فتره طويله نعم طرحه وهي عهود
على الدول وايضا هي حلول مشتركه بين الدول
تحدث عن الكواليس واهميه الكواليس وتبادل
الافكار في مثل هذه القيم همم القيم وهنا
سؤال استاذ استاذ اسامه همم وكان ضيف
الاستاذ خالد ومراقبون اخرون كذلك يعودون
على الصين على موقف الصين القادر على خلق
معادله جديده اذا ما ثبتت موقفها مع
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وتمكنت كذلك
من خلال هذا
الشكل الجديد من التعاون
ليه اخراج همم العالم من ازمه او من ضائقه
الاقتصاديه هل تعتقد بان الصين يمكن
التعويل عليها سياسيا كما اقتصاديا
يعني ان اجيب عن السؤال اذا كان يمكن
التعويل عليها ام لا اجابه صعبه نوعا ما
لانني لان الصين دائما لديها حساباتها
الخاصه واحيانا الامر يبدو جدا مبهم ولكن
ما يمكنني ان اقوله الصينيون ممكن ان تلعب
دور مهم جدا جدا الولايات المتحده
واشركعها الاوروبيين خاصه او الغربيين
بشكل عام خاصه بريطانيا وايضا اليابان
سيحاولون وهم في هذه اللحظات يحاولون ان
يقنع الصين في هذه القمه ال20 ان يتم وضع
سقف لاسعار النفط لان كما نعرف اسعار
النفط ترتفع يوما بعد يوم ومن المتوقع ان
ترتفع اكثر ايضا ابتداء من الخامس من شهر
ديسمبر المقبل مع دخول العقوبات الاوروبيه
حيز التنفيذ او الحظر الاوروبي على نفقه
الروسي حيز التنفيذ بالتالي ما تحاول
القيام به الولايات المتحده هو اقناع
الصين بالقبول بهذا العرض وحتى يعني تقديم
تقديم عروض للصين ولا الهند ايضا للقول
للصين والهند يمكنكم همم متابعه شراء
النفط الروسي باسعار ارخص في حال فوضتم مع
روسيا واستطعنا ان نضع سقف لاسعارنا فقط
هذه نقطه النقطه الثانيه تتعلق ايضا
بالمديونيه ايضا الولايات المتحده تدفع
بالصين الى تخفيف اعباء الديون عن الدول
الفقيره هناك دول تعاني جدا اليوم بسبب
لان المصارف المركزيه حول العالم رفعت
الفائده لمكافحه التضخم وهناك عده دول
مثلا مثل سريلانكا التي عانت مؤخرا من
ازمه هذه الدول تستدين بالعملاء الصعبه
بالدولار باليورو وبعملات ايضا اخرى
بالتالي رفع الفائده سيؤثر عليها جدا
بالتالي الولايات المتحده تطلب من الصين
ان تخفف يعني اعباء الديون بالتالي لهذا
السبب الصين لها دور مهم تلعبه في هذا
الشان ايضا للسين دور من خلال التوصل ربما
مع روسيا من اجل اجداد حل للحرب حاليا
الدائره في اوكرانيا كانت هناك يعني مواقف
لافته للرئيس الصيني الذي قال في هذه
القمه انه يدين استخدام الطاقه كثيره حول
الغذاء كالسلاح وهو نوعا ربما انتقاد
وصفها البعض بالانتقاد مبطن لروسيا
بالتالي نعم يمكن للصين العظيم
لانه يمكن ان يكون تصريح موجه لروسيا ولكن
حتى الولايات المتحده الامريكيه التي
تعمدت ان تبيع الغاز لمن تعتبرها
الحلفاءها في الغرب ولكن باضعاف السعر
الذي تبيعه بداخل فهنا يمكن ان يكون هذا
التصريح موجه للكل همم ولكن همم دكتور همم
دكتور فخري الكل يتخوف من ركود قد يعيشه
العالم همم هل نحن اقترب نعمل مشارف هذا
الركود اعتقد وما هي مؤشراته
دعيني انه يعني انوه بان في سنه 2008
استطاعت قبه ال 20 تخرج بالعالم من الازمه
الاقتصاديه العالميه في 2007 2008
لكن لم تكن يعني هناك حرب دائره بين قوه
كبرى في 2008 اثناء الازمه الاقتصاديه
العالميه همم اما الان هناك ازمه اقتصاديه
ايضا عالميه ولكن هناك صراع دائر بين همم
صراع الروسي الاوكراني وما خلفها من دول
تدعم هذا الزراعه في هذه الحلقه قد يؤدي
ذلك ولذلك همم في بدايه همم كلماته همم
وجهت بانه لابد من ايقاف هذا الصراع بكل
السبل الدبلوماسيه وغير الدبلوماسيه في
هذه الحاله حتى يكون المجال المفتوح امام
دول مجموعه ال 20 اللي بتمثل حوالي اللي
بتنتج نعم الانتاج العالم و75% من التجاره
الدوليه و60% من سكان العالم او الثلثي
سكان العالم لهذا بنجد انه كثير من الدول
الناميه تعاني المعاناه شديده ولذلك فيما
يتعلق اذا لم تسرع البنوك او التناغم بين
سياسات النقديه المتشدده للبنوك السبعه
الكبار ال جي 7 في هذه الحاله هذا التناغم
بالاسراع بكثر حده التضخم يعني سريعا حتى
لا ندخل في عام 23 في من تباطؤ الى ركود
وهذا الركود في هذه الحاله سيصعب الامور
على الدول المتقدمه وايضا كافه
وتصاحب المساله
بالديون وحل مشكله الديون القادمه شبه
الديون وايضا اشكر الاخ همم العزيز خالد
العوضي فيما يتعلق من الربط ما بين همم
المناخ قاب توينتي انت ساكن مع السلامه
وبين اهله
ولكن انتهى تماما توقيت الحلقه بقت لي اقل
من دقيقتين اود ان اخدمها
معك همم استاذ خالد فيما يخص ما تفضل به
ضيفه من تعداد كيف يمكن الخروج او على
الاقل عدم الوصول لمرحله الركود هل تعتقد
بان
يمكن ان يكون ذلك في همم عقليات همم
القاده الغربيين خاصه وانه هناك كما تعلم
منافسه غير مسبوقه على دور الرياده في
العالم الصين روسيا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه فهل هناك تعتقد نوايا حقيقيه
لذلك
ثانويه موجوده ومعلنه لكن عن ان ان ان ان
نستطيع ان نخرج من دوامه الركود هذا طبعا
صعب جدا هو الارقام هي للركود تتطلب من
سته شهور الى 12 شهر يعني في نهايه ديسمبر
راح نستطيع ان نعرف حقيقه احنا في ركود
اقتصادي او لا
اقتصادي هو عدم النمو في اقتصاديات الدول
ولكن ما هو اسوا من ذلك والانكماش
الانكماش الاقتصادي للدول العظمى وعدم
النمو او النمو السلبي هو ما راح يؤثر
وانا ما اعتقد ان احنا رح ندخل فيماشات
كثيره في عديد من الدول
المهندس خالد العوضي المستشار في شركات
هوك للطاقه شكرا لك من القاهره الدكتور
فخري الفقي مساعد الصندوق النقد والسابق
ومن باريس اسامه حريري المحلل السياسي
شكرا جزيلا لكم على المشاركه والحضور
ولا نقاش دائما بقيه ولكن نعود بالغد
نناقش مختلف الملفات الاخرى السلام عليكم